I see you oh I see you over there hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to subnautica I just tested
the limits of my oxygen capability
because I swam from my base to the
surface and it is just barely there but
now I'm gonna go back I need to make I
need to get the materials for a
bioreactor um and I need to get
materials for various other things I
want to get enough to make another room
so I can get to bio reactors but one of
the things that I discovered yeah oh
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] was
that oh my god
you silly playful [ __ ] you scared me
yay yay yay I don't like that
thank you I don't I don't like the idea
of you playing like whales just
breaching out through the water
oh so majestically ever welcome back I'm
headed back to my life pod I will be
skipping at in just a bit to get the
materials get my seam off and then get
back but before that I need to get
materials I need to make a second base
but one of the things that I discovered
is that lantern fruit are an amazing
source of energy in a bioreactor so what
I need to do is I need to get enough
titanium to take with me over there so
that I can make two bioreactors and then
make the grow beds to be able to make a
lot of lanterns so I got a long way to
go but I just want to pop in to say
hello
so a la dee da oh I'm an idiot I have
this thing oh I'm just [ __ ] you are
you kidding me god dammit I'm such a
[ __ ] doof [ __ ] whoopee-doo pee here
we go [ __ ] them and [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] all y'all I'm getting you know
I know I know
I know I forgot how hard life was
without this stupid mobility a scary
life was oh no we've got a message oh no
oh no
rora is Sunbeam we've made orbits and
scans have found a landing site on the
planet that's only rated passer dhis
it's our best shot we've sent you the
coordinates we'll be there in two days
time
cross your fingers the weather holds and
don't leave us waiting Sunbeam out well
that's not good I am not prepared for
that I can't turn off although people
have said that I can't turn off the uh
oh boy yep that's gonna be bad it's got
a gun on it it's got a big dangerous gun
you're gonna die so there's no way to
turn off the gun right now uh but that
may change in the future but I think
they're gonna die I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure they're gonna die but we've
got better things to do with our life
we're gotta go get our seamoth back
we gotta get bubble butt we gotta get
enough materials no I'll get food you
out of here nope oh I forgot the
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall are
over here but I'll get them later time
to worry about that now okay so as I'm
gathering materials have got some more
people's names to read so thank you for
commenting down below salad exists one
says there are four leviathans in
subnautica not three in case you didn't
know and I'm doubting this a little bit
but they say it's Reaper Leviathan sea
dragon sea Emperor but then they also
say there's a ghost Leviathan
and I'm not sure how much I believe that
I think that might be something that you
made up but I have no way to prove it
otherwise so I appreciate the daring
that you have next up is phantom 17 just
some random facts about the warper that
warper is actually a cyborg created by
the ancient aliens and it's robot half
itself is what makes it able to teleport
so that's that's fascinating V the
aliens made the warper and I believe I
believe I read that somewhere as well
and I just I don't think I've ever
talked about it it's really interesting
to see that the ancient aliens built the
warper and I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure that the purpose of the warper was
to corral and collect all of the
infected creatures and bring them to a
controlled environment or possibly kill
them now I don't know which is which but
I know it just probably isn't good news
for anybody involved okay next up is
Christian for ant 3 who said make plasma
gun with knife to kill Reaper Leviathan
and I don't know if that just means I'm
gonna get a plasma gun and then attach a
knife to it and it shoots a plasma
infused knife at a Reaper - and it kills
it that sounds awesome I want that I
think they may be mixing up dead space
with this game but I'll forgive them for
now because that's his name cool and we
have gods 17 rag on 18 who said mark you
need to delete the files name cells cash
and compiled octrees cash in your save
files this will make the game go
smoother now I have not done this number
one because I'm hesitant to go deleting
files in my save game file but if it can
make it a little smoother I might be
interested in doing that but I don't
know if that's just to work around or if
that's actually something that's gonna
help me in the long run but we'll see I
just don't know okay so that's all the
names that I got thank you everybody for
commenting and now I've got the
I've got my seamoth now all I have to do
is get as much titanium as possible
before I get out there the only problem
is I only have 18 slots for titanium and
I think that's gonna be enough because
if I build another basic chamber I would
probably have enough to make two
bioreactors and then I should have
enough extra titanium to build whatever
I do need maybe some more solar panels
just to bank more power even though
they're not gonna be making any power
they do add power bank so that if the
bioreactors are constantly going then
maybe it's gonna keep me powered but
again I won't have the fuel for that
until I get enough bio creatures which
just means I'm gonna become an
eco-terrorist even more than I already
am and just start nabbing fish out of
the sea and feeding it into the horror
that is my bioreactor also I have to be
over by the island in 30 minutes to
watch the Sunbeam explode okay so we've
got just about as much titanium as we
can hold I picked up one piece of silver
because I'm pretty sure I'm gonna need
maybe two pieces but I know I can get
silver down there so I'm not
particularly worried about that but
we've got all the materials that we need
I'm pretty sure and we've got a beacon
to guide us down into the briny depths
of Hell where I know my base shouldn't
be but it is anyway because I'm an idiot
and we've got three diamonds which means
that I'm gonna be able to make that
drill arm wait am i I'm checking my math
here no I am NOT cuz I don't have a
[ __ ] plasteel ingot well shitty tits
oh well that's a problem for another
[ __ ] day [ __ ] but alas I shall not
get mad about that it is not a big deal
because now I have
think that I need to be able to go down
there and then upgrade all of my
capabilities except for the [ __ ]
drill arm to be able to get more stuff
out of the diggie holes but that's okay
again because I have confidence and what
I'm going to be doing down there so I'm
gonna go ahead and get to the build
phase and then whenever it's about five
minutes left on the Sun beam I'll
probably take the old seamoth out and
witness the fireworks the Sun beam
exploding in a fiery hell hole which
should be fun you know frankly I'm okay
with that
I'm gonna get a bowl of popcorn and I'ma
set atop the mountain and just watch it
it's still pretty it's still terrify up
there goes the music and now it's
terrifying it was more pretty and now
it's more terrifying okay so what I'm
gonna do first is I'm gonna focus I'm
gonna focus on the bioreactor the first
bioreactor because I should have
everything that I need to build one
emergency power
oxygen oh yeah oh I know wait you should
be rotated hey pep-pep but I uh
Podolski okay so now a reliable power
source is a crucial step towards
self-sufficiency if you're not already
considering keeping a photo journal of
your achievements to remind you of how
far you've come since washing up here I
wish you took automatic pictures because
that would be kind of cool but I don't
have time to worry about it I'm actually
recording everything so it's not a big
deal but now I need to build another
base extension
I should have planned this better I
should have planned this much better
because I didn't I didn't put a lot of
room to be able to do this oh well
whatever who cares if it's gonna be
halfway in the mountainside it'll move
for me I think it'll he'll move it'll
move for B right yeah it moved yeah it
moved for me yeah okay I get it all
right okay so there was some fishies
sorry you're gonna be subjected to
horrible fate and a toss to do a beat
grinder and turned into electricity
don't ask me how I don't understand the
technology with which I am building well
I know is that you need to be set well
you're pretty woman whoa I got an a I I
don't know what a tie is I didn't even
know the aye-aye existed I've never seen
the aye-aye before in my life
well time to toss him in the meat
grinder oh well wonderful new things and
notes did evolve the sea predators
before they see it well they didn't see
me coming so too bad for it
all right let's see this all right what
can we put in here nah did not mean to
eat that okay that I is eat yay I've got
power power yay okay so that that gets
power very very very slowly and I'm
beginning to think the B the solar
panels are actually doing absolutely
dick diddly oh look I've got some
mountain in my room that's okay but
since I'm able to build two and
constantly fuel them with a steady
supply of lantern trees I should have
everything that I need to be able to
build exactly what I need so with that
being said I'm going to make this the
crew area because it seems to already be
halfway blasted out so I'm only gonna
need one for now so I'm gonna build one
yeah
back I want to build this one for now
happy to meet you boo boo boo feels like
home and I'm gonna put I'm not gonna eat
you switch there we go okay so that's
gonna grow up all big and strong
oh it's getting there it's a little oh
look at the little Billy I see him
growing already what a lovely little guy
okay so that's gone I've got one which
is not a lot of power but enough and
then I'm gonna get another one and
finally I'll be able to dock like
frickin seamoth my frickin other thing
in here oh it seems brighter already
oh is it daylight was this just cuz my
bass is powered that's awesome it has
power it gets light oh that's so nice it
is so much brighter is that just like
faint shining on me sorry I I you gotta
go oh it's so nice oh you're quick oh
you're quick ancient oh you're quick oh
you could not that quick haha not that
quick haha I feel bad I don't all right
dupa dupa dupa I do think I do think
it's I do think it's brighter down here
like I don't know if I'm just feeling
peppy because things are going my way
finally but you know it's a little bit
kübra no and you know what else is cool
I'm gonna be able to make a water
filtration machine which is a really
really ridiculously cheap machine to
make like constant supply of water water
filtration it only requires two titanium
which I don't have I gotta go back and
get it but by the time I come back here
I should have absolutely everything I
need and I should have lots of power and
everything should be cool and hunky-dory
so I'm gonna go on one more titanium run
I'm gonna come back here and by the time
I come back here it's gonna be plenty of
power it's freaking bright as [ __ ] here
you know what I'm gonna dock I'm gonna
dock a dog I shouldn't say that over and
over again but I'm gonna dock right in
oh oh
thrust butthole
yes oh
emergency power literally power restored
Oh pirates I forgot that that was gonna
charge that thing well I bet it's dark
out here now Oh nope still little bright
okay well it's hanging halfway with its
ass out oh oh that's adorable
oh it's farting up a storm oh how about
that okay I'll come back when things
aren't so terrible right so now I just
got to go get some titanium I think I'm
pretty sure I still have time to go get
titanium and then come back before the
Sunbeam explodes so I can make some even
more improvements to my base before
everything goes to it oh come on stop it
well my bass is not happy I'm getting
like spam stop it I'm getting like spam
messages over and over again about how
my bass is terrible also I'm gonna go
out and get the necessary materials for
plasteel which is not a lot I think it's
just lithium and a titanium ingot so I
should be able to do that one-two punch
get it in get it out and be done okay
all right we got oodles and oodles of
titanium now and we've got one titanium
ingot and I just need to swing by the
purple mushroom area and grab a lithium
because I'm pretty sure they're down
there and if I'm not mistaken there's an
entrance to the purple mushroom area
right down here in this hellhole right
here yep I was right I know this place
way too much which I probably shouldn't
because it's super scary and I hate
going down in this one yeah is this
always so disconcerting the way it Bob's
you back and forth and the way there are
worms inside the mushrooms it's not okay
man it's super weird
but I'm pretty sure there's lithium less
I'm horribly mistaken and incredibly
stupid
the Hecky heck was with I um hey Lizzie
um I knew it I knew it is there anyone
that's not near a freaking shark yes yes
okay all right good grab there is with
that in there rough graba this around
[Music]
OOP okay so I don't think I'm need more
than two I think plasteel is just
literally one but just to be sure how
[ __ ] do-do-do-do-do whatever yeah what
have we got what if we get where was I
doing
PLAs stealing it here we go how about
you yeah I only needed one with you but
I'll hold on to the lithium just in case
so I have a whole bunch of [ __ ] I've got
up oh I've got oh why is it all blue why
is it blue and blocked out I don't know
but I got a bunch I've got a bunch of
titanium I get plant stealing it
I've got three diamond I've got an extra
lithium an extra silver and I've got
these ion crystals that I don't know
what they do but apparently they're
gonna explode okay so now we got ten
minutes I'll be cutting it really close
but I think I can do it I think I can do
it
I saved but I think I can do it I think
I can gun it all the way over to my base
build it stuff do the things then gun it
all the way back keep no time wasted be
super productive this whole time and
it'd be super awesome and cool otherwise
everything is gonna go to [ __ ] and I'm
not gonna be able to get anything done
which is also an option ha ha ha
I haven't even made the modification
station have I've no I have not
I'm not gonna be able to build it anyway
why the [ __ ] you [ __ ] god dammit I'm
such an ass oh ow oh ow
wait this power for what this power it's
just the warnings that are [ __ ] Oh
oh that's great oh that's good oh that's
good okay what do I need to do to build
a goddamn modification taste that's what
I want to know right now computer chips
oh well I can't make that oh [ __ ]
alright well this still has Spadefish
and that's still working so these are
still technically working which is good
it's working very slowly and ah man I
need oh I need one more silver don't I I
don't have that no yeah I need one more
silver and then table coral sample which
I think I can get here I'm pretty sure
ah [ __ ] I need to be able to drop my
stuff off which means I need to be able
to make a locker let's do it in here I
like it in here anyway the walls are
pretty barren okay hey babbit do you
know what
this lockers better I won't be able to
put a name on it but it's bigger sure
musky there's this temporary don't
anybody get upset about this I just need
to store things for temporaries while I
go hunt for what I need which is very
important okay all right so if I just go
hunt I know for a fact that you can get
silver out of the deposits around here
but I'm gonna be close on time because I
got to get over there in the next minute
if I can just find [ __ ] I forgot ah
[ __ ] I need to repair this thing
god dammit I'm such an [ __ ] alright
ah ba ba all right let's just let's just
do it before I blow it up somehow cuz
I'm gonna blow this thing up
I know ah and [ __ ] I'm out of time god
damn it
ah all right I'm going back I got to go
back I'm not gonna try to cut it short
I'm gonna go back now I'm not gonna risk
it you know get silver no bring that
back table coral oh yes it's so hard
when you're not cheating but I'm not
gonna cheat ever so I'm not doing that
so that's why I have to deal with this
this is what real life in a fake life
game is like gotta work for what you
want you got to work hard and get what
you want so you can get what you need so
let's go watch the Sun beam blow up and
people get killed that's the horrible
thing to say okay I could probably have
cut a closer I probably could have gone
and made the stuff that I need made the
computer chips and then made the
modification station then haul ass over
that probably would have been perfectly
acceptable but for now we are here and
yeah I don't feel like it's gonna be
good I feel like it's gonna be a bad
thing should I write SOS in the sand and
just you know try to hope for the best
maybe they'll miss me maybe it'll miss
maybe it's gonna miss me it'll miss you
no that's not [ __ ] baby baby I think I
literally think I think I'm pretty sure
that the marker here is literally
telling you to stand here because it's
the best view to watch it explode and to
watch the gunfire which I've been
looking forward to I have not seen this
gunfire and I've been tempted because
I've seen videos and stuff I say like
the precursor gone firing but this is
the real deal
I just wish that target reticle would go
away oh whoa oh oh oh oh oh oh God oh oh
uh look out oh oh no oh no oh no
uh okay I think that might be the
warning okay
badging in a local broadcast from the
Sunbeam there's someone down there yeah
Aurora survivor we have your PDA
signature oh hi I don't know how you
walked away from that wreck let alone
survived since then we'll be happy to
bring you on board and hi exhale back to
Federation space stand back
we're approaching the landing site now
braking atmosphere in five four three
what is that the red one oh boy oh boy
oh boy
[Music]
well TAS not good oh that sucks oh
that's no good I wonder if there's any
Salvage I can recover I doubt it
oh man what and now the guns just in
firing position
oh geez well oh hello friend did you see
that
yeah it was [ __ ] awesome what that's
mean someone got shot so anyway that is
all the time the nav for this episode to
subnautica ended on a high and a low
note but alas we are stuck here on this
planet until we solve the problem and
maybe forever this might be our home
here a lone lost scared and afraid
hey that's half the fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]